hello everybody and welcome to the
eighth TV basics tutorial video with
Python in this video we're going to make
a sort of drawing application so to do
that from where we are it's actually not
very much code because we are already
tracking on touch down on touch and on
touch move we actually aren't going to
need on touch up but I'm just going to
leave it here because it's cool that we
even have that so with that let's go
ahead and import one more thing and that
is going to be from TV graphics we want
to import line with a capital L and
that's to actually draw a line basically
now what we want to do is on touch down
we want to begin a line so think of like
you know you have a pencil you put the
pencil to the paper and it starts to
make a mark and then as you drag it
around it continues you know marking on
the paper so that's what we kind of want
to do is want touch down if we want to
begin that mark and then we want to
continue that mark as long as our touch
is moving on even though in theory you
might think in your head well don't we
have to do something on touch up to stop
the line drawing no because on touch
move will just cease to exist anymore so
we actually don't need to do anything
there but anyway uh we need line and
that's really all we have to add as far
as imports are concerned and now we just
need to code the on touch down and move
stuff so I'm going to call this uh I
don't know
draw clash draw input and then before we
forget we need to take this right here
and instead of touch input down here it
needs to be draw input so I just want to
change that other than the other mat
we're ready to go so now we say with
self dot canvas and this is the canvas
of our application so self dot canvas is
just referring to that so you don't
really need to like define canvas or
anything so with self dot canvas what do
we actually want to do well we're going
to say touch dot u D and you D now we're
going to reference the line element in
there and we're going to say that is
equal to
line and we're going to say the points
over that line is right now going to
only be a single point in the line but
the points for now are equal to touch X
touch dot Y so literally the x and y
values of where we touch down so line at
the moment is literally just actually a
point it's not really a line it's simply
a point but then what we do is we've
since we've got that now what we're
going to do is that should I'm going to
just make sure we close that off right
yes so now we've got a line there and
that will actually show something but
not very much and now on touch move what
we want to do is we're going to say
touch UD and then again we're
referencing the line element whoops
line like this and then we're going to
say dot points plus equals and we want
to plus equals the exact same thing
pretty much right here so plus equals
this so again this is just the this is
the line function we're saying we
already established touch UD line equals
line which we imported up here and where
we say the points of line so where we
basically said line dot points because
touch UD a line is equal to basically
this line right up here so now we're
saying line dot points which originally
line dot points was touch just X&Y of
the original touch now we're saying we
want to add to those points and we're
adding every single movement of touch X
and touch y we just add all of those
movements and that's really it that's
all we have to do with this and so now
we can just save and run this hopefully
and here we have our application and
yeah sure enough you can click and you
can start to write things so hi awesome
and then we can actually you know resize
this and we'll see that okay we just
gained a lot more space and now we can
write even more stuff and I'm really
good at writing with the mouse tutorials
you probably won't even know that was
tutorials immediately
anyway so that's that that's pretty much
all of the basics for using canvas
anyways but that's pretty cool like how
quickly you can actually you know
reference the drawing ability in the
canvas ability of TV so anyways I
hopefully you guys enjoyed if you have
any questions or comments please please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support subscriptions and until
next time